good morning Hank it's Monday and you
may not be able to tell this from the
fact that I'm just saying in front of
radiator in a wall but I'm in England
today's a really really big day for me
it's actually kind of an enormous day
because today my book scarlet fever goes
on sale everywhere well a lot of places
mostly in America but that's really big
deal and what am i doing to celebrate
I'm sitting in a little room oh my god
oh my god no you know every deadline
brings with it its own special magic in
the same way that the poisonous fugu
fish brings its special magic to certain
lucky diners I'm not complaining mind
you I'm just externalizing my interior
monologue now you may be asking yourself
Maureen you're a professional writer
what do you need deadlines for is the
book just done when you're done writing
without deadlines only about three
authors I've ever met would ever turn
anything in because the books never done
you're always still working on it it's
only done when they pry it from your
cold half-dead hand and even then it's
not done because you want to still keep
working on in there's mistakes in it
there's stuff you want to change but the
thing is that if you're in publishing
they have to sort of draw a line under
it and say give me the book deadline
this week is for the sequel to 13 little
blue envelopes and it's the draft is due
on Friday so that's why I gotta sit in
this little tiny room but that's fine
because as it happens I like sitting in
little tiny rooms right oh my god most
of the time because I'm writer and that
is this is the whole job you sit in a
room and write that's if you don't like
that then you shouldn't do it in fact a
lot of times people ask me no maureen
chevy writer is that a good career path
is that something i should be and you
know what my answer is it's not actually
a career path at all it's crazy it's
like being a driftwood sculptor or or an
interpretive dancer trust me i am
shocked and thrilled
every day that I get to do this for a
living not that many people do it's
incredibly awesome and I'm very very
lucky but also I'm not gonna lie to you
it's a lot of work it's an actual job a
lot of teenagers write to me and say I
want to write a book I want to get
published and those are two very
different things for the first one that
you want to write a book I think is an
excellent idea and you should totally do
that because teenagers who want to write
you should be writing you should be
writing all the time like maniac don't
worry about the second bit just yet
because a you need a lot of practice you
need to do it for I'm not kidding
years and then once you are published
it's a business it's a job plus every
author I know was that teenager who sat
in the room and read and wrote that's
who becomes an author but that's what
you have to do for a while before you
become an author plus you haven't
properly learned to procrastinate yet it
takes years and years of experience to
gain a level of mastery required to
become a professional author because let
me tell you we are exceptionally good
for example you will be tested on your
ability to make a fort I made this one
in under 30 seconds but that's because I
am a professional if you have any
questions about writing or the
publishing process you can leave them in
these comments or send them to me on
Twitter and maybe I can answer them in
my video on Friday which will probably
be my last until then I hope you enjoy
scarlet fever if you have it and Hank
I'll see you on Wednesday